bueno la primera reacción es un
comunicado oficial del ministerio de
exteriores chino que ha sido lanzado
pocos minutos después de que pelosi
aterrizará en el aeropuerto señal de que
estaba ya preparado acusa a eeuu de
romper sus acuerdos de 1939 en los que
se prevé en visita hacer estadounidenses
no oficiales a la isla y hace ver que
difícilmente la de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes- puede ser
considerada no oficial también repite
una vez más que taiwán es el asunto más
conflictivo entre las dos potencias
acusa a eeuu de frecuentar a los
independentistas y les recuerda que debe
respetar el principio de una sola china
no hay nada novedoso y tampoco sorprende
que haya anunciado y al inicio de
maniobras militares en el estrecho de
formosa cabe subrayar el riesgo porque
en esa zona están juntando ya numerosos
barcos y aviones de guerra tanto de
china como eeuu como de taiwán y el
peligro no son las malas intenciones
sino un
o imprudencia
ya lo hemos visto en el mar del sur de
china cuando hemos estado a punto de
rozar la tragedia
porque barcos y aviones de china y eeuu
se han acercado mucho más de lo
recomendable ese o eso es en mi opinión
ahora lo más preocupante y nos hablas
adrián de la del punto de vista de china
pero como es vista esta visita entre los
taiwaneses
bueno para taiwán que está siempre a la
sombra de china y peleando por hacerse
ver en el mundo es sin duda un gran
triunfo que una alta representante de la
política estadounidense acuda a la isla
y es seguro que el gobierno utilizará en
su provecho esta visita pero taiwán
también sabe que solo es un peón en la
estrategia estadounidense de preservar
su hegemonía y frenar el auge de china
en ese sentido son muy realistas los
taiwaneses yo recuerdo que en tiempos de
donald trump un alto cargo del gobierno
taiwanés me decía que no iban a dejarse
arrastrar en esa dinámica y que no
podían atar su futuro a las necesidades
de washington y que en realidad eeuu le
importa tanto el destino de los
taiwaneses como el de los iraquíes o el
de los a planos taiwán además sabe que
este no es el mejor momento para el
éxito habría sido mejor en abril pero
pelosi tuvo un positivo por kobe y se
tuvo que retrasar todos los factores
explican que el gobierno no haya
alardeado demasiado el viaje para no
irritar más de lo necesario a pekín y
que tampoco la prensa la epe esta
excesiva atención es para lógico que el
viaje a taiwán he recibido menos
atención en taiwán que en el resto del
mundo